a full one minute and 20 seconds of
logos does watching an extended cut of
the movie also mean extended logos cuz
this movie and the logos it wrote in on
as we stare into the barren desert here
for a few seconds I'm starting to wonder
if maybe this movie is just two hours of
desert footage with the occasional
tumbleweed rolling by because I bet
Favreau could direct that bet are those
tumbleweeds towards absolution oh cool
it's a talking okay Paul got iron on his
wrist he's been shot for those viewers
who did not spend the last two minutes
witnessing the obvious attributes of
Jake Lonergan situation this guy's here
to provide unnecessary info to not only
you but his dad I said walk we all know
that double O Stetson here is going to
take out all three of these guys but can
we at least pretend to make it realistic
I mean the guy on the horse weights a
full ten seconds before missing at
point-blank range also anything is
possible but the act of turning around
and immediately stabbing a guy who was a
good five or six feet behind another guy
while still holding the gun on some
other dude is not and this guy died from
a single knife to the leg I mean maybe
if you hit the femoral artery or
something it would still take a bit to
bleed out right no clue this is but
might be useful for white material later
so I'll hold on to it oh yeah that whole
major stomach wound thing that was
forgotten for the last couple of minutes
a horse riding over multiple terrains
I'm calling bullshit on him getting off
that horse a second ago as smoothly as
he did without crying or passing out
palms to heaven friend this is the kind
of thing you write for your preacher
character to avoid writing a cliche like
hands up partner but it's also the kind
of phrase you replace it with that
indicates your movies going to suck only
two kinds of man get shot criminals and
victims that's incredibly sage I was
thinking about all the other non
criminal non victim types of the world
and realized that none of those people
ever get shocked
I don't know also pro tip if someone
gives you two choices go for the one
that will save your ass playing the
middle card doesn't usually work out
well in situations such as these what
are you gonna end up in heaven or hell
it's not God's plan it's your own even
when Clancy Brown is playing a good guy
he comes off like a religion spouting
serial killer you know what guys I saw
in the opening credits that Olivia Wilde
is in this movie and I still haven't
even seen oh there she is
I'm glad that movie checked in on her
well back to the movie scene backs up an
expression I once heard it goes
something like wherever there is Paul
Day know there will be blood
on here the real question should be
where the for you Sheriff when Percy was
shooting up the outside of the saloon
also a movie automatically gets a sin
for having a Carradine in it because I
have to figure out what you wanted is
every time I think just wear a name tag
along the lines of I'm the one that was
on Dexter Taggert you know that's not a
good idea well I'm afraid I got no
choice man
Adam each ladies and gentlemen doing the
copy dad next time you can make the
coffee
okay actual dialogue in this movie uh uh
I could give this movie credit for not
having the henchmen talked about his
boss and then the boss is standing
behind him thing but then we have to
watch this guy start to take a few movie
maybe it's possible Roy would have
survived with no injuries being that
close to an explosion except that he
wouldn't considering it looks like they
just stacked their wanted posters like
flapjacks isn't it just a tad bit
convenient that Jake's just happens to
be right on top Favreau cameo Cambria
and no respect ins we get it Sam
Rockwell is a timid barkeep bald Dana
was a spoiled brat and Daniel Craig is a
badass amnesiac did we really have to
spend the first half hour of the movie
on these plus a half dozen other
different backstories it better be
revealed later that jake has some sort
of magical powers because with no clear
mirror across from him there is no way
that he could know he was about to be in
danger by simply the sound of them
approaching the door hey guys needs an
action scene let's have the sheriff and
his deputies completely botched basic
arrest procedures so that we can have a
big saloon fight I don't want any
trouble I don't want any trouble cliche
considering about a hundred head of
cattle or still smoldering in pieces
what does dollar on I think the city had
actually did hear you saying I killed
this woman you tell me movie has spent
its first half hour West earning so hard
that win or if it ever decides to start
alienating the movie will be in for more
of a jarring shift than when I learned
to drive stick nearest I find it odd
that not a single person in the
sheriff's office thought to ask about
Jake's wrist accessory or try to remove
it even if they don't think it's
dangerous it sure looks like it might be
worth something I don't like it here
paws get in order when he doesn't simply
any year who even is this kid why is
this movie all percent lonesome dove and
no percent Independence Day did they
miss title the movie wasn't supposed to
read Cowboys or aliens Cowboys and
Aliens asks the bold question what if
aliens attacked a quiet western town in
the 1800s and there wasn't anything to
give a damn about Blazing Saddles get it
because it's the Old West and the aliens
are lassoing people
like a cattle herd I guess the aliens
were also using 1800s technology for
their abductions back then they figured
out space travel but not the tractor
beams just yet I mean I guess you got to
do what you got to do but does dollahyde
really think this will work okay well
just a gall-darn stuck in there cowboy
did your alien jewelry activate because
of proximity to the spacious why would
it immediately go into gun mode and how
would you know that and how did you even
know how to shoot it or did it just
happen to go off when you had it pointed
in the most convenient direction and yes
el explains eventually that the
technology works through his mind but he
doesn't know what the thing is so why
would he think to use it as a weapon so
not only does he understand how this new
unexplained risk gun works
he is also already a perfect shot with
it good to know an alien managed to find
its way into this house with nobody
seeing it apparently it didn't smash any
windows and politely close the door when
it entered the residence also nobody
checks on the person who got attacked by
the alien after this even looks in the
house for clues I don't know what it is
Adam Beach ladies and gentlemen so doc
is actually a doc but he runs a bar and
the preacher was stitching up Jake
earlier I think this might have been a
more interesting movie if it had been
about a town of former doctors on the
run that lost their licenses Cowboys and
now practices this might be the only
movie where someone is actively trying
to get away from Olivia Wilde by being
vague and not telling Jake exactly what
you are what that technology is on his
wrist yeah it was a big help
sorry son you can't go it's too
dangerous I'll watch him on the ride was
it really the ride that was going to be
too dangerous or was it the unexplained
technologically advanced psychopathic
alien race thing cuz I bet it was the
latter it's heading north judging by the
horse shadows and the fact that its
first thing in the morning this posse is
clearly riding the opposite of north
which makes sense since this movie's
been heading south for quite some time
now got a kid in the dog why not a boy
that's just all kinds of hist I get that
the house is bringing back some of
Jake's memories but how did he remember
the house I had to get back to it so if
the aliens can melt and suck up gold
through a roof but they still need to
use ropes to abduct people know much
about boats
I'd say that one's upside down oh great
maybe just turned itself into the
Poseidon Adventure
also sure let's grind this Cowboys and
Aliens movie to a halt by giving them
their Saving Private Ryan everyone gets
to know everyone better in close
quarters moment how's that feel
it's heavy fin it will be that's already
over two hours and we're almost an hour
in with only one instance of cowboys
fighting aliens we have plenty of time
for the Meacham teaches doc the
importance of gun scene we also get
almost a full minute of Daniel Craig
looking around this boat does it mean
anything it'll be important later
this in the previous sin I have to ask
does this movie even understand the
concept of editing no no and hell to the
no don't wreck the look telling you any
stories listen when you tell them to
Percy them stories weren't for you are
we really trying to jam yet another
sentimental plot line into the bloated
carcass of a script the preacher's faith
the bartender's wife the deputy's kid
the amnesia acts love a strange woman's
identity and now daddy issues in her in
the mix ever Oh keeps looking around his
Red Room for more toys to play with and
I really wish I could remember my safe
work it's hard to dislike Harrison Ford
so the movie makes sure he takes a bite
of this Apple just to prove he really is
an actual asshole when the target peeks
up over the top the squeeze and treated
poor shadowing practice I mean target
practice in darkened close quarters
where you aren't actually sure where
everyone else is is a bit like eating at
a gas station restroom sherry you'll
probably be fine but why the hell did
you even bring the burrito in there in
the first place Roger guys I've been
watching this movie for an hour and this
is the weirdest James Bond movie I've
ever seen like and wet-and-wild here
obviously knows some valuable
information but since it's not time for
us to know yet she isn't telling anyone
else either because you know why help
when you could just stand there
rain-soaked and touch about a wound
seductively so just a bunch of
disease-carrying creatures that could
bite you and kill you but sure just sit
down and hope for the best okay I know
the boat is kind of big but certainly
this kid and really anyone in there
heard those alien roars right dude
wasn't even pretending to keep it on the
DL those are some super dry and freshly
pressed clothes after being drenched the
previous night tracks are good headed
north
Howler's tracks still good exactly there
was a monsoon the previous night in fact
they should just be standing in a pile
of mud right now I'm gonna say some say
some words over well he wanted to knows
what to say is in the ground ain't it
enough we took the time to put him there
why exactly do they take the time I get
the whole being respectful to the dead
bit but there's a pretty serious time
crunch right there trying to track down
the aliens and save their friends and
family that are possibly still alive so
maybe just say a quick prayer and skip
the time and energy it would take to dig
graves and bury these people here all
over
he said young I am definitely feeling
the same way as that guy did right about
now what did you do movie - Santa throw
even more new characters at us over an
hour in because it's a Western and it
hadn't found any way to Goggins yet we
do the camp
remember how just a few seconds ago you
were hot on the trail of an alien
monster creature that kidnap your
friends and loved ones but sure let's
take a break and visit your old buddies
camp for a bit
seems productive you huh the Scottish
pronoun game is the same as it's played
in the States but it requires subtitles
and a glass of Spring Bank 21 years
single cast to play gymnast oh sure go
ah the demons took your gold excuse it's
the dog ate my homework of the Old West
kill though so hold on does he have to
wait to hear the beeping before he can
use his wrist gun an ex machina or can
he shoot it whenever just asking because
I need to know if I'm sitting this for
the plot convenient times it turns on or
his stupidity and not using it as a sign
of power earlier and someone explained
the alien bombings to me if they're
abducting then why are they bombing
their human subjects well this is ship
doing exactly just riding alongside them
is the alien pilot finally kidding to
live out his dream of being a pace car
word on the street is that this is how
Jason Sudeikis ended up impressing
Olivia while before they got married men
will do a lot of stupid things for a
living a while including jumping on a
speeding spaceship but for some reason
hasn't flown off into the stratosphere
like the other ships have done so far
also for the love of VIN timing that
jump at that speed and hanging on it's
like John Ford directed a fast and
furious movie and all for artistic
choice he were there but why make the
decision to saturate these colors so
deeply on just this walk was the goal to
see how fake it could make the sky look
because great job you made it look very
fake
tenaris did it better
you gotta love how the gentleman
Lonergan rushes to do the right thing to
cover the naked Ella but make sure to
get in a really good look before handing
over the blanket I'm sorry yes yes you
could have and the fact that you will
never even attempt to give a good reason
why you kept your identity and knowledge
secret is proof enough for me that
you're full of whatever the alien
version of this from a different place I
took this form so I could walk among you
I made sure that I packaged myself in
the hottest possible way so as to be
less conspicuous also this movie just
stepped into a huge pile of work when
you haven't even explained the aliens
and introduced a species of fire
resurrecting goddesses your movie is so
far off the rails it's a 1984 Pontiac
Fiero also also what did we expect when
we saw three Studios at least five
riders and 15 producers on this thing
ranging from the lost guys to the people
that brought us cocoon and Steven
Spielberg not to mention the guy who
gave us Iron Man and swingers but also
gave us a thorough and Iron Man - I know
if I could heal this body if I would
wake up it's pretty amazing how people
from the 1800s especially the Native
Americans who were blaming all the
monsters on the white people just allow
this dude who was a prisoner to talk
casually to the naked woman who just
rose from the dead without a peep you're
a guest of the chief now I'm a guest I
thought it was a prisoner
Looby captures an actual question
Harrison Ford was asking and puts it
into the movie they want gold well
that's just ridiculous what are they
gonna do buy something New Mexico Jones
would be excellent at cinemasins
they'll come back with more and there
will be no survivors it's what they did
to my people oh yeah because I just saw
you Alien Resurrection yourself after
being gutted in barbecue so I'm not
exactly sure how your people could die
in the first place and one will be
seated during the magical healing
hummingbird portion of the movie it's
not great when a movie that has a budget
of well over a hundred million dollars
has a scene that doesn't look any better
than the Zapruder film quality of alien
autopsy they don't see well in daylight
a standard ground in caverns where it's
dark that's why they decided to launch
an aerial assault in the middle of the
goddamn daytime a few minutes ago
also the more Wild West he responds
important information that really would
have been nice to know before the more I
can't believe that they haven't thrown
her into another fire we have one
advantage they underestimate you
you're like insects to them then why am
blue blazes are they spaced rodeoing
folks to study their weaknesses
just smash the bugs and carry on with
your interstellar mining he says it's
better to fight from high ground Apache
have clearly studied Obi Wan's ancient
texts on battle it's just me or did
Walton here take a trip to the dentist
while we were away because when his
teeth got jacked up earlier they look
like this best use of our resource
always good to get a little
foreshadowing practice I mean target
practicing but aren't they super close
to the alien ship I know the light is
supposed to affect their vision but does
it somehow affect their hearing as well
[Music]
this movie obviously has much more of a
hankerin to be Western and sci-fi and at
about a 90/10 split which might be fine
if the Western II parts weren't the most
boring as parts of the whole experience
I mean it took three writers and Damon
Lindelof to come up with a speaking
script
none of us hair very long I see you've
moved on from that very recent vision of
the previous love of your life being
chopped up and disintegrated by aliens
pretty quickly good for you man complete
your happiness horses landscapes
camouflage alien lairs excitement this
alien race is technologically advanced
enough to achieve pulse weaponry and
space travel but not simple perimeter
security like motion detectors or
cameras and sure Lawrence of Olivia
tells them the aliens don't consider the
humans to be threats but why can't the
aliens be smart for a change when we're
conquered by a superior alien race this
movie will be shown in a class called
the downfall of man under estimating the
unknown by Bork's people Beck's majesty
since they are using a type of card
board matchbox that wasn't really
invented till much later let's just tack
on another 20 sins for all the other
anachronism seen in this movie that
didn't exist till the 20th century like
stainless steel knives waterproof makeup
and Daniel Craig's so much for them not
being able to see in the daylight
thanks for nothing space lady Cowboys
versus Predator hello dreamed of riding
movie Oh get Percy
it's your son Adam Beach ladies and
gentlemen mere seconds ago the aliens
were obviously destroying the Cowboys
but now the Cowboys are getting the
upper hand
why hell if I know and he'll if the
movie is going to give any indication
why this unstoppable force just turned
into Keystone Cops for a few minutes
don't with it tonight
why didn't you shoot it in the first
place then how long I'm gonna be like
this each one is different how does she
know has she done this before also why
the fuck did the aliens need to put a
bunch of people in a trance absolutely
none of this alien makes any sense maybe
it doesn't have to but it doesn't have
to do it
they killed Lana Gran's wife and then
everybody else the Pennywise no use of
their motor functions for days and
possibly weeks but I'm sure they could
just walk right out of there I flee
these aliens follow video game rules and
only come out you one at a time now that
I really get a chance to look at it I
guess internal hands is a bit of an
evolutionary design flaw and you can
control it any way you shoot it with
your mind you have to stop thinking this
is all it took to get the alien fit bit
off his wrist why didn't it happen
before when he kissed her I guess it was
controlled by boners and this is the
first time his penis didn't have amnesia
if I can get it to its core I can stop
them well that ended up being pertinent
to the plot good think Jake was never
one of the ones captured or killed or
had his arm cut off by someone in his
sleep
what is this recording why does it start
playing and why did it just happen right
now just answer one of these questions
movie Nigeria and it just happens to be
the exact same alien that discount Jo
bang sliced up and escaped from earlier
because of course it is even though this
alien cave labyrinth is likely confusing
in foreign and it's highly unlikely he'd
know where to go the movie can't help
but Harrison export Acala verse before
it comes to a conclusion it's hard to
believe that this isn't the only time a
character died by pouring molten cold on
them in 2011 it wasn't even the first
time as several stories of this rocket
emerge from below the earth I think it's
fair to ask exactly how did that bad-boy
land in a way that buried it perfectly
that deep
go team and all that but after a while
when the scouts haven't come back won't
more aliens just come out and find out
what happened to them I guess that was
the sequel the sequel
Percy boy regarding Percy your father
Star Wars nerds boner alert if this
hummingbird is supposed to be his wife
that's going to be very tough news for a
sex life I think the more appropriate
question is how many more scenes of this
do I have to watch before I'm driven to
drink and the answer is negative 59
[Music]
bitch stole my gold off the bouillon
coach I want that man you find this
thing they don't see well in daylight
they stand her ground in caverns where
it's dark once again things that could
have been brought to my attention
yesterday I'm your father well I
understand double those have a very
short life expectancy so your mistake
will be short-lived I've seen good men
do bad things bad men do good things
sure people have long faces a long
people have short faces nobody calls me
colonel like indiana renamed the dog
Indiana what kind of a man goes around
blowing up other people's cows that's a
lot of cows
on me would you have any Grey Poupon